en pleine épidémie de coronavirus la
crise migratoire se poursuit en
méditerranée l'île touristique de
lampedusa en italie doit aussi faire
face à en affluent pression' ans de
migrants ces derniers jours au total
plus de 2000 demandeurs d'asile sont
arrivés la semaine dernière sur la terre
sicilienne de nouveaux arrivants pour la
plupart originaires de tunisie pays en
proie à l'instabilité politique et où le
taux de chômage explose selon les
chiffres du gouvernement italien
sur les onze 1191 migrants arrivés à
lampedusa cette année 4000 étaient des
citoyens tunisiens une vague migratoire
inédites dont sont témoins
quotidiennement les habitants locaux
impuissant ce qui se passe ici c'est que
tout est hors de contrôle
ces petits bateaux qui arrivent de
tunisie il y en a trop trop et nous ne
comprenons pas la raison pour laquelle
ces gens fuient
je ne suis pas pour ou contre
l'immigration mais je pense que les gens
en mer doivent être sauvés une fois sur
le terrain les gouvernements feront leur
travail
un afflux qui pose un important problème
de gestion
le centre d'accueil sur l'île ne
disposons que de 95 places d'hébergement
face à cette surpopulation environ 300
migrants ont été redirigés vers d'autres
centres notamment en calabre et dans la
région des pouilles
un ferry a également été mise à
disposition pour envoyer des centaines
de migrants en sicile des arrivées
massives qui pose aussi question qu'en
pleine crise sanitaire
le premier ministre a dit que nous
devrions mettre automatiquement les
nouveaux arrivants en quarantaine
il n'y a plus d'espacé pour placer les
gens dans les centres par conséquent
nous devons accélérer les transferts
la situation est claire soit on obtient
la collaboration du gouvernement
tunisien
c'est à dire qu'ils commencent à bloquer
ces bateaux directement avant leur
départ sinon les arrivées se
poursuivront à ce rythme pendant tout
l'été
une situation qui alimente le débat
politique en italie
si les humanitaires dénoncent ou le
manque présumé de solidarité avec les
nouveaux immigrants et les obstacles
auxquels ils font face la droite
nationaliste accusé la coalition
gouvernementale de restée passive face à
la crise migratoire comme en témoigne
cette passe d'armes au parlement italien
entre le premier ministre josé paix
compter et giorgia meloni
la chef du parti frères d'italie en coin
les fâche
comment avez vous vécu infliger une
amende aux commerçants qui sont sortis
sur la place à qui on demandait de
l'aide de manière ordonnée
comment avez vous pu fermer les
entreprises de ceux qui n'ont pas
maintenu les distances sociales
comment avez vous pu chasser les gens
sur les plages à l'aide de drones
alors qu'aujourd'hui vous autoriser des
milliers de migrants clandestins à
entrer sur le territoire italien
ceux qui violent nos frontières et qui
violent leur quarantaine en errant
inutilement même si elles sont testés
positifs
comment oser linke diable faites-vous
pas cher face à la grogne des italiens
et la détresse des migrants
le gouvernement a annoncé que l'armée
allait désormais assuré la garde des
centres d'accueil de navires de 600
places chacun seront également bientôt
disponible pour déplacer ces nouveaux
arrivants